[Music]
so as you dome into this how much did
you find that there was a disconnect
between what people talk about online
and what they talk about in reality
because I'm guessing it was a lot easier
to get straightforward answers sometimes
with keepo online if you contacted them
versus how hard was it to get people to
actually talk to you about this stuff
people that didn't want to be shamed or
silent you know they want to be heard
obviously which is why they're on these
message boards but then maybe they don't
want to be publicly yea exposed to have
their face attached to it
yeah well oddly enough there I didn't
have that part of a time interviewing
Emma raised a few feminist backed out
when I was planning to interview them
because they were worried of getting
backlash for memories if they were a
part of this film but the Emery's were
excited to talk to me because most most
journalists don't want to reach out to
them and talk to them and that's really
unfortunate because I you know I think
you should go to the source if you're
reporting on someone or something but
they were really open with me and Paul
Elam was the first person I contacted
from a voice for men and he led me to a
lot of the leaders within the men's
rights movement and each person is
different in their communication style
as well as their their ideas and beliefs
and perspectives on these issues so the
film shows you know kind of a
well-rounded look at what Emma raised
believe yeah this is gonna be a little
insider baseball stuff but like when you
are going ahead and you're doing a
documentary and you have one intention
when you start and when you see that
intention change you have people that
are funding you through various ways
you've had it whatever your backers are
and whoever else has helped you made
this did you have to go to people and
say you know the intention of what I
started here really is very different
because people have certain intent they
don't give you money usually just for
their own edification they sort of want
something at the end so did you feel
that you needed to go to people and say
you know this thing's really changing so
when you see the cut yeah you know I'm
warning you well okay let's talk about
funding because that's actually
something that I've been attacked about
from mainstream and feminist uh so when
I started making this film first off I
was self financed
it and my boyfriend who's the executive
producer and DP the director of
photography and our routine so he was
also helping finance it and my mom was
who is a producer on the film so it was
the three of us and we all
self-identified as feminists at the time
and so that got us through filming but
while we were filming and even after I
was submitting to film grants and that
was my first attempt to get outside
funding for the film and so I submitted
to about 15 film grants and something
that was really interesting was that
they all have categories and genres that
they want you to check off the boxes of
what your film falls in line with right
and so it'd be environmental issues or
racial issues LGBT and then it would say
women's rights or women's issues but
there was nothing for men and so a
couple of the film grants I ended up
just checking the box for human rights
because that was the only one that
really seemed to fit but many of them I
didn't have any kind of genre to put in
a box for this film right did you feel
like if you clicked women's rights that
they would just immediately like no no
not going to happen I don't I don't know
probably feminists I suppose that are on
those panels watching them say yeah a
chance with human rights I guess yeah
and you know in hindsight we do talk a
lot about women's issues in the film as
well in relation to the conversation but
I just thought it was interesting that
there was you know my film it fit in a
box for anything and so we got tonight
from every single grand and we didn't
even get to the second round
many of these film grants who have a
second round or third round until you
get the grant and so you never even got
through the first round so I thought
okay well that's too bad so the next job
is to go to my previous angel investors
and see if they wanted to finance the
film and they all denied money to fund
this film most of them said we don't
want to see a film about Amar'e's
because why would you give them a
platform to speak this is exactly what
they want they want the media attention
and you're just feeding into their you
know misogynistic rantings by giving
them a platform mistake right I shall
say guys look at look at this and maybe
it'll change your perspective a little
bit I mean we're paying were people even
willing to watch it or was just like
well the film wasn't edited yet I had
100 hours of footage but I even I was
confused how I was going to put all this
together
to our film but I was trying to tell
them I'm I'm first of all I'm going to
show what the MRA platform is because
that's what most people don't know
anything about but I am going to address
the feminist point of view because
that's where I'm coming from and just to
bring some balance to it so it's not
just a commercial advertisement for
emerets what they believe and so I kept
saying I'm going to bring a balanced
perspective like I have with all my
previous films and most people didn't
think you could have the balanced
perspective how could you have balance
volume raise it's just they are wrong if
feminism is right that's the only
discussion yeah so again these are the
Liberals these are the tolerant people
right yeah and and that's all my
connections were in that world my
previous cylinder about women's rights
and LGBT issues so so they all declined
I did have one feminist organization
offer funding and I ended up declining
because I knew that they wanted to make
it a film for their agenda and I didn't
want to have that looming over me as it
would no longer be my film so so I
declined that and because of that I had
no other resources to go to for funding
I was dried up of my funds my boyfriend
my mom so in a last-ditch effort I was
ready to shell while the footage and let
it collect us and I was so emotionally
drained from making this filming going
through this process of questioning my
beliefs that I was actually kind of
relieved at the idea of like alright if
no one's to see this film and I don't
have the funds to make it put it aside
at least I have the benefit of going on
that journey and being a better person
from it having less resentment and my
own relationships and feeling actually
more empowered as a woman after this but
I'm not a quitter
as I thought okay I have to put
something out to the universe let fate
take control and see if I can get
finishing funds for this so I put it up
on Kickstarter and I was very clear in
my video saying that in order to make
creative control
I had to decline partisan funding and I
want to remain just how I want to
present this film in a balanced way so
will you help me complete this film by
funding my Kickstarter and that's when
we had almost 3,000 people support our
Kickstarter and raise twice as much
money than I was asking for yeah well we
found this show on patreon I didn't have
about three thousand people that do it
and to me as I say
all the time it's like I'm my audience
has a huge wide political belief and
philosophical belief and it's like I'm
beholden to a few people that have all
kinds of beliefs and all they want me to
do is say what I think and I think
that's probably ultimately what you
found ooh did you find that you had
people then who gave you whatever they
gave you that then we're trying to push
you in a certain direction like oh
really no I and maybe it's because I
kind of stayed off line I was really in
my hobbit hole of editing from after the
Kickstarter was done until the film was
released I really and my Kickstarter
backers could probably tell you that I
didn't I didn't give a lot of updates I
wasn't in active online that much so and
I I wanted to remove myself to have that
creative control and not be influenced
by the people in the film or the
Kickstarter backers and and you know if
anyone asks any of them
yeah they had no control over telling me
what to do yeah you know how much do you
think all this stuff is related to other
things going on in society right now
like there's so much going on with
social justice warriors and all the free
speech stuff and you know trigger
warnings and safe spaces a lot of stuff
that you know I talk about on the show
constantly as someone that now sees
things a little differently do you see
these trends in other movements as well
yeah absolutely and I think the SJW
thing and the safe spaces and the
trigger warnings microaggressions and
all that I think became more heightened
after I completed my filming time uh and
so I think it's just just it's been
bubbling up and getting even more
intense since yeah I would say like 2000
early 2015
what do you think have you seen it kind
of I mean it it seems like it's getting
more and more and more but I do see a
push back against it now which is why
when I tweeted out that you were going
to be on the show people were excited
because now they're the people are not
afraid anymore to say oh there's this
new group of people that are lining up
and are willing to at least have these
discussions and not you know cast
aspersions on everyone we disagree with
and all that but the reason I ask is
because just this week I saw an article
in The Advocate basically they were
saying that Peter Thiel who's given
money to
Trump and spoke at the RNC that he's not
gay he has sex with men but he's not gay
because you know he's supporting a
Republican nominee and that sounds so
mad absolutely ridiculous but I see a
real parallel to the type of stuff that
you're doing
he's obviously gay I mean he identifies
as gay Yeah right
and yet because his political beliefs
are a little different
who's throwing him under the bus now
it's the left that's very disappointing
and I think that's probably the reaction
that you're getting at the same time
from people in the same quarters yeah
well I I think I'm like you in that I've
been a liberal for my entire droll life
and now I'm starting to become extremely
annoyed with the liberal party and I
think I remember one of your interviews
saying that some of your fans criticized
you for being so critical of liberals
but wasn't your answer something like
well I I just hold your side guy these
are my team like everyone I could attack
the right all day long but everyone does
that I would like the Liberals to be
liberal again right and when it's your
own family are more critical because you
have higher standards for for your
platform so yeah I've been extremely
upset with the regressive left and
feeling like they're not no longer the
open-minded freedom of speech party and
and yeah and I'm very annoyed with
identity politics and and liberals
acting like okay if you're for women for
for gay rights if you're for a black
lives matter
then you're a liberal and but if you're
a woman or gay person or a black person
that's a conservative then you're not
actually for women or for equality you
know it's right there they're drawing
this line but it's not it it's like
liberals are wanting to claim we are the
open-minded free speech equality party
but but only if your arms with us right
they want to pretend they care about
minorities and I believe that they do
care about minorities in a broad sense
but I've credited ayaan Hirsi
with this many times over lea time ran
that the biggest minority is the
individual you have to care about
minorities within the minorities and
that seems to be what they completely
forget I'm curious and I have no idea if
you even know about this but is there
are there other countries that are
dealing with these issues better that
are dealing with this sort of in a more
mature way like is there some Western
country that maybe is treating men in a
more even-handed way or something like
that like Bowie or anything like that
all right because I would guess in these
forums you probably did come across some
people have different places yeah well I
know there's a huge men's rights groups
in other countries like India especially
I know you do that the rape laws there
do not include male victims and also the
pressures on men to provide for the
family and for their elders and just I
couldn't speak to much about it but
that's the general understanding that I
have is and then also in Sweden the
feminist movement there is extremely
powerful and in my film we show that
they tried to create a man tax at one
time where that men would have a higher
tax to pay for the women shelters for
female victims of domestic violence and
that was their way to deal with it and
it didn't pass but there's a stronghold
there and the leaders of the feminist
movement in Sweden are also connected
with the leaders of the feminist
movement in the US and they're all very
much tied together and something a lot
of mris talk about is radical feminism
and when I was a feminist hearing that I
always thought well that's the fringe
that's that doesn't represent the whole
but the thing that people need to
understand and do research about to
understand is that radical feminists are
the ones in power with the funding and
the Lobby power and and they are
steering the ship and so unfortunately
most people who identify as feminists
don't understand that and also don't
call out the radical feminists and and
it's just this kind of hands-off
approach I mean like the feminist
blogger who's been attacking
me I haven't seen any feminists call him
out publicly and say hey what you're
doing is wrong is she
Cassie J hasn't even said that she's not
a fan feminist anymore all I said was
that I was doing a movie about the men's
rights movement portraying in portraying
these topics in a balanced way letting
everyone speak and just for that just
the fact that I would talk to em raised
and let them say what they have to say
they drew a line on the sand and said
you're no longer with us if you're not
or if you're not with us or against us
you're the enemy
and so radical feminism is really the
issue and it's more powerful than I
think people realize yeah so where do
you think the men's rights movement I
mean literally I don't think I had ever
even heard of it before maybe a year
maybe I don't even know if it's that
long actually um where do you think it
needs to go I mean obviously now and
with your film it's going to get some
more buzz and more people will be
talking about all that well where does
it actually have to go to get some of
the some of the laws change for example
when it comes to custody and that kind
of stuff like what's next you need a
real political movement behind it is it
just you needed to start in cool and
culture like what is the next piece well
let me first say I'm not an MRA I'm not
a menace I'm a documentarian I just went
on this exploration I made myself the
guinea pig as the feminist who's
learning these emerets talking points
and challenging my own views so I'm not
an MRA but but what I think they're
trying to do moving forward to help with
men's issues is is first of all is
understanding the issues and that's
really what my film goes into is just
the 101 on what are all the issues with
workplace deaths war deaths suicide
poison school infant male circumcision
father's rights domestic violence rape
laws list goes on over misandry male
bashing in in the media so first
understanding the issues and because
there are so many issues the solutions
are a case-by-case basis I know the
National Coalition for men which is
based in San Diego the headquarters one
of the big initiatives right now is to
is work
the Selective Service and not quite sure
if they're trying to abolish it or make
it gender neutral but but the Selective
Service or are you familiar with that a
little bit that not really actually so
what I think people should know right
now is that still every 18 year old boy
has to register for the selected service
or he could be fined up to $250,000 or
spend five years in jail and so he has
to do that and or he won't get a
government position or certain
scholarships if he doesn't do that so
that is still on the books even though
most people would say oh the draft wait
that's old news we don't have a draft
anymore so it's not a big deal but it's
still on the books and the last draft
was Vietnam and 17,000 over 17,000 men
died that did not want to go to war and
when I talk about war deaths and as far
as men's issues oftentimes I'll hear
from feminists well the women kind of
serve in combat it's another way of
dismissing this men's issue and and I
think for me personally you have to put
yourself in either shoes would you
rather not be allowed to serve in combat
and wish that you could or died in
something you didn't want to go and do
right and so the draft is one of their
next initiatives that they're trying to
push forward and now Hillary Clinton has
said she doesn't want to expand
Selective Service to women and so in
most countries women are included but
it's in war work so administrative tasks
clerical tasks yarter I think was
driving like a truck during World War
two not not in the in the field but like
you know some sort of hospital thing or
something yeah and she's a feminist
thank oh yeah um I would be remiss if I
didn't ask you what you thought of
Ghostbusters that would really be if we
get through this whole thing and don't
talk about Ghostbusters did you see it
number one oh you're all gonna hate me
no I didn't you didn't see it
see there I don't know what I'm gonna
watch it on Apple TV the other night and
then I just couldn't book what do you
think about the react without even
seeing it when I think of the reaction
so they obviously remade it with all
women to me the first Ghostbusters and I
think the second was pretty great too
but I think it is the it's the perfect
quintessential 80s New York edgy funny
movie the enemy is the government which
is kind of funny a lot of people say
it's like the first libertarian comedy
which I thought was really great
near the Environmental Protection Agency
is the bad guy basically in the movie um
but what do you think of just the
general reaction where that trailer came
out it did not look good it just simply
did not look good the the dislikes on
the YouTube video were like I don't know
it might have been twenty times what the
likes were but there was this
implication that because people didn't
think it was funny or didn't look good
that they hated women yeah very much
goes into the wheelhouse of everything
you're talking about what did he make of
that whole thing well and I wonder how
much the media was playing up that if
people are against this film is because
they hate women or they're misogynist or
whatever and that actually helps get
feminists to support the film just to
you know in spite of any haters so yeah
the film didn't look good from what I
saw the trailer and I you know I do
think it blew up more because of the
controversy around the film and it
wasn't a good idea to begin with I mean
it's like iconic film why why do
something like that but uh what do you
think it's weird that they say all right
well now we're gonna do this with all
women like I don't I don't think anyone
really ever thought of the original
Ghostbusters and maybe I'm showing my
male priviledge here but but really
thought of the original Ghostbusters as
if it was a male film because it was
just it happened to be all men doing it
but they could have remade it with three
women and one guy or or now they're
making Ocean's eleven I guess with all
women like I have no problem inherently
with any of those things but it does
seem like something just seems odd about
it yeah
you know there but they have the right
to do it I suppose in it if it's good
it's good and if it's not it's not yeah
I yeah I mean I guess they can't I don't
know if they're gonna be successful yeah
uh yeah I don't know what the yeah is
that a funny thing though that at the
end of the day Hollywood just like
whether you're making
many like you are or you make Anna Boch
Lester they just want to make money so I
guess if they at the end of the day if
they make ten movies that they remake
with all women and they don't work no
matter how much the feminists wanted to
work eventually Hollywood's gonna be
like no we're here to make money not to
not to prove a point yeah and and there
are different viewing patterns for male
audiences and women female audiences uh
you know reality shows for women like
female waste reality shows like the
Housewives do very well and they're in
just like gaming for guys do well it's I
think men and women and this is
obviously being you know kind of
generalizing and stereotyping but we do
have different interests and I think
it's okay for people who decide what
kind of content is put out there to play
into the female interest in the male
interest yeah why are we so afraid of
our differences like that I've been even
saying that there's like a tone of like
I don't want to put down a girl that
happens to be a gamer or a guy who likes
whatever like why are we so afraid of
that do you think I don't know because
there I think there are differences and
they're good and and if a woman wants to
become a kindergarten teacher rather
than going into stem that's okay and let
her do that and more power to her that's
a job that should be respected and not
look like she was held down by the
patriarchy to do that you know it's what
do you think of the phrase the
patriarchy it's become so ludicrous to
me that like now I use it on Twitter as
a joke basically but like do you think
there is some patriarchy here some
system been in place that we're all
subject to that I shouldn't be so
mocking of yeah I so as far as I know
the the idea of patriarchy really
started to come around in second wave
feminism in the 70s and originally it
was capitalism that was the enemy Erin
Pizzey who started the first women's
shelter in the UK she saw the shift
happen where capitalism was the enemy
and that's what was holding minorities
and women down and then the second wave
feminists decided to make it about
patriarchy and it's it's a very good
marketing strategy because because what
feminists will say is well you look
around and you see the patriarchy you
look at the white house you look at see
positions you look at who's running the
television stations it's all men and I
even feminists will say we need women's
studies because every other class in
school is men's studies even math even
science or language it's all because men
wrote math and so it's it's men's
studies right so it's it's a good
marketing ploy because you could say to
a young girl who's maybe a bit naive
that yeah look at some it's a man's
world we never had a female president
and that's proof but think of all the
people living in the world and how many
women mothers had power and control over
raising up the next generation and
couldn't that be looked at as major gave
a sort of women having so much influence
on on kids and you know when your brain
is a sponge so yeah the patriarchy it's
I don't believe we live in a patriarchy
I don't believe all men oppress all
women and I think we have different life
experiences some involved from different
gender roles and not necessarily from
discrimination but sometimes sometimes
from discrimination but mostly from
biological reasons putting gender roles
in place and it seemingly working to
raise up the next generation of because
gender roles really exist within family
structures if you're an independent
person you have plenty of working women
without kids and you know they can
actually outward men male counterparts I
so gender roles really exist within the
family and it seemed to work and and as
far as historically speaking you know
people say oh that women have been more
discriminated against historically they
couldn't vote they kind of do this that
any other thing and what I learned from
MRA is is that discrimination against
men and women were not apples to apples
they were different men were going to
war being drafted working long hours in
the coal mines and that is its own form
of sacrifice women were also beating the
rugs outside and doing the dishes by
hands and cooking meals and having lots
of kids without reproductive choice or
rights so so the ways that men and women
were
and also privileged are different so
let's end on a purely political note
since we this is also a couch around
politics but that's no purely political
because we do have a woman that could be
the President of the United States in a
couple of weeks I would argue I don't
know that she would either be right
woman or if she was a man that you would
be the right man for the job
but I know assert there's a certain
subset of people that just want a woman
in now I suppose you don't see a lot of
validity in that just in the in the
token portion of it right well that's
sexist to think that okay it's like just
based on their genitalia that they're
they're going to be better I just want
to make sure you were gonna throw me a
quick curveball right at the end yeah so
that um but in a weird way would it
would it help feminists by showing good
go at me here for just a second that
Hillary could be as sort of corrupt and
ruthless and whatever as any man could
be because that I don't see at this
point I don't even see I don't see her
as a man a woman I know she's a woman
but I think she's as whatever you have
to be to be a politician she as is it as
any man and I guess maybe that's the
best compliment I could give her as a
woman I was at that's I like how you
worried about that I was like actually
it's irrelevant whether she's a man or
woman but she obviously can play this
game yeah so if people think it's rigged
against women she's she's doing a hell
of a job with it they like her a night
I'm gonna go out on the limb here and
say she actually has more advantage for
being a woman because it's unassuming
that she could have that much power and
use it for less than good reasons so
when you see something like I saw a lot
of people were saying that during one of
the debates I think it was the second
debate when Trump was kind of walking
around behind her and they do have a big
stature difference in size alone I mean
he's a tall guy and she's a small woman
I did think there was like there was
like a little visceral reaction to like
this big guy lurking around this little
woman where if it had been two men I
think most people wouldn't have seen
that did you see that at all see
B weirdness in that well I saw the shark
video we're done
oh yeah that's from that moment yeah did
you see anything there like it's this
big guy he's kind of lurching around or
like it just felt kinda weird and maybe
that's my own prejudices of you know
wanting to defend the woman there's oh
no I didn't see that so maybe I just
think I'm a woman isn't a I don't know a
target of violence just for being a
woman or something yes you're a little
more red pill than me I don't know uh
yeah I after making the red pill I
actually feel extremely powerful as a
woman and I don't intend to use that for
you know bad reasons because I think
some women learning about how much they
how much power they have within this
culture that if you're the oppressed
gender then people want to give you help
give you assistance give you
opportunities to lift you up and so you
kind of have this actually
disproportionate amount of privilege and
opportunities handed to you just for
that fact so you know I don't want to
use it to you know step over someone
else but but now I do realize like yeah
if I'm walking down alleyway and I
scream I feel like I would have a chance
of a guy coming to help me and save me
because I'm a female screaming but if it
was a guy saying hey hey help help I you
know most I mean I wouldn't go to help
him because I'm thinking well maybe I'm
not I wouldn't be the one to defend him
but I do feel protected in some ways by
the men around because I do think a
majority of men are good and and so for
being a female I think you know good
guys want to help women like you did
with one it helped Hillary from Trump
yeah so I guess the final takeaway is
that we should treat people as
individuals would that be fair to say at
the end absolutely
all right there you go all right well it
was really a pleasure talking to you and
you guys can find out where you can see
red pill check out the red pill movie
com
[Music]
you
[Music]